[Music]
alright holla holla holla holla ha
Said's boobies fleur-de-lys ooh a little
bit later on the show I have my Eagle
Saints reaction I'm not gonna give that
to you right off the bat because that
you haven't heard all right you guys
stick around for the podcast stick
around then I get that we have an update
on the bank accounts right after that
incredible divisional weekend call by
you there's an enormous swing in that
Cowboys Rams
I pretty much ends it and I'd like to
hammer this home one more time Dan
Tana's in the CNN center at the Super
Bowl right near the stadium and radio
row and hotels Tuesday at 5:00 Wednesday
at 5:00 Thursday at 6:00 Friday at 4:30
they continue to pour in
we are gonna pack this house we are
gonna be filled to the brim we're all
drinking tequila and we're haven't
hanging out talking about ball to
everyone that keeps DMing me or or
hitting me up on Twitter Email Sims and
left Co at gmail.com say your name how
many people what night you want to come
by and then Josh will put you into one
of his patented spreadsheets and will
make sure you get in there it's gonna be
a blast gonna be a blast
I know sign o Atlanta you know it's
interesting if the Saints get to the
Super Bowl I was worried that there was
gonna be a lot of Saints fans there
mm-hmm
but Atlanta fans don't like Saints fans
either so I'm just gonna be an Atlanta
guy gonna be Atlanta guy yeah okay I'm
here for the locals here for the locals
yeah they won't be around why cuz the
Saints fans will be there oh they're
just gonna avoid it altogether yeah
they're the incredible thing about the
NFL's dunk slam dunk the Saints can beat
the ran so I know well we're gonna get
that's on Wednesday and Thursday
yeah the NFL Films is incredible your
you have got to see it for a long time
because your family's been with it your
dad show on Showtime they always have
really cool snippets they turn NFL plays
into magic that we never forget it's
part of the reason I love it the sable
family what's truly incredible I think
is how quickly they turn it around I
have a friend in Mount Laurel that NFL
Network yeah that gave me a sneak
preview about arguably the biggest play
of the weekend so I'm gonna play it for
you cool so
sit back and relax Nikki ready okay here
it is
I don't like that one I wasn't that
wasn't it's one of the good interval
films songs right there though that was
really good
oh here it is here's the right was your
friend know you're about to get them get
them fired from NFL Films by sharing
this all my friends know that at one
point or another I'm gonna get him fine
are you ready service yet on a cold and
windy day in Kansas City the Chiefs were
walking peacefully to a win but no one
knew about the carnage that was going to
ensue fourth quarter under 4 minutes
left
mahomes lets it fly but on the ground it
happened a referee with the force of a
thousand suns charged into the unaware
love handles of Chris Sims lifting both
feet off the ground launching him into
orbit and stamping his legacy as the
greatest playoff Punisher we have ever
seen grown men wiped their spectacles
and shocked women and children called
their Sheriff in fear and while the
spleen --less wonder remained standing
Chris Sims will now and forever be
revved up incredible so happy that you
survived I was really worried about it
and for you to be the moment of the
weekend Chris congratulations only I
could outshine Patrick mahomes hunter
just mr. Grayle the pen really cool yeah
yep no I was totally sober yeah knocked
me to the ground I mean come on lyd
judge get a little power you know you
getting smoked what number was the line
judge you know oh I asked our friend
Matt camp yeah and I said do you know
that is and he believes IV give me the
numbers Zimmer Steve Zimmer if you give
me the number I got he could be right
Steve field judge Zimmer yeah it could
be Steve that was the guy that ran into
you I think so I guess if we could see
the number on the back of his thing I
could tell for sure we'll go look at it
in the background guy he'll get my ear
okay but I have so many questions what
happened I would like your official
response you texted us I'm gonna save it
for the pod
take me through you're standing on the
sidelines
and Patrick mahomes lets it fly and what
happened okay
so first of all I'm not even supposed to
be on the NBC postgame show okay
and I'm warm and cozy sitting inside the
trailer watching the game and she had to
get on the field well no I'm not I'm
they tell me that there might be more of
a postgame than they anticipated and now
that I might have to get involved right
I'm kind of like cool but I'm also like
damn I just thought out from being out
there for us out there for four hours
right and I froze my butt off so then
okay so I'm on my way I'm making my way
down the field making my way and of
course it's great because Kansas City is
winning the stadium's electric and I'm
not complaining that I have to go watch
Patrick mahomes in person on the world
in a big moment or whatever so we're
down there we're kind of getting set up
uh and I'm watching the game and of
course the Kansas City's winning and it
becomes a third and four I'm thinking
you know they're running the ball out
paying attention double digit or just
few people in the stands throwing
snowballs so you had to be back keep
your head on a swivel a little bit
because like you though which is
unbelievable I don't know they were
trying to hit me or Rodney I think most
of them are aiming for Rodney Harrison
but either way so I'm sitting there and
I'm just like okay yeah they're gonna
run out run the clock out that third and
four happens he drops back to pass and
I'm like oh my gosh he's throwing the
ball and I knew and I could see Tyree
kill and I'm he's coming right at me and
I'm like oh man this is awesome this
Tyree kill here he is coming right at me
oh my gosh he's gonna make the catch
and that was like what and as soon as I
had contact was made by like Sue's
caught I didn't even know who was but I
promise you as soon as hands hit me I
was like oh no it's the ref I mean all
the times I've been on a sideline in my
life that has never happened to me it's
the number one thing they yell about and
if you look at the video I were not on
the white I'm not on the white and I'm
literally saying sorry as I'm still
skinning going backwards yes so hard you
get hit yes what is the conversation the
conversation is get the [ __ ] out I mean
that and a bunch of cuss words any you
know gave me a good shove didn't knock
me down let's just remember takes a
little more than that but yes so I am
literally got oh as soon as he's pushing
me and I'm skidding backwards I'm good
my bad I'm sorry and he looks at me and
he stares me down and I mean I think
sighs I think even said like [ __ ]
idiot like one more time right
I think whatever I don't even know what
he said at the mall but but then he
really didn't know who you were
I don't think he did I some of the other
reps did cuz they came over and looked
at me were like I was like you know I
was kind of like signaling like bad they
were like giggling at me but so now it's
the next play and he is you know in
setting up again
oh now you're watching the field so now
I'm watching and I have another chance
of him being right next to me and I'm
still apologizing and I'm going I am
like I go I'm really sorry that's my
fault I'm a dumbass I don't know what
else I can say
and he said well at least you know it
and that was the end of it Wow they know
it and then in DC people were laughing
at me like something like the producer
of the pro football talk shows a guy
that helps out on you know football
night in America Matt Casey they're
right near you
oh he couldn't stop laughing now when
did your phone what I don't think I was
done skidding out yet like I was
literally like kind of gathering my wits
and I could feel my phone in my pants
just vibrating non-stop and right as I
started to feel it I was like oh
everybody saw it Sims yeah my phone
exploded I don't see it at first glance
either no and then all of a sudden was
you see your boy you see your boy huh
your boy haha your boy Josh was at
graduation yeah his brother's graduation
Madison I I wrote it all cold in all
capital letters we have a Code Red
yeah you just got pushed by a Ralph's
Code Red and the thing is he pushed you
yeah he pushed me he ran in and didn't
have to and then felt the need to do a
full extensional extension good thing um
after our a little walk through to our
pregame show I had dress shoes on okay
but it was so muddy over there I
couldn't believe you were your LeBron
and it was so wet you're wearing your
little obscene LeBron we're the same one
that's why LeBron soldiers are a great
investment for everybody out there
this Sims a left go Bobcats sponsored to
you by LeBron James why because just
8tracks well yeah I mean they don't
believe you're out there in the snow
bronze yeah because there's shoes I like
it well see this is what's awesome about
LeBron you could throw them in the
washing machine and they will come out
looking brand new but I had to because
my feet were frozen and - it was so
muddy and like so much snow no dress
shoes I couldn't what you couldn't I was
slipping everywhere one of my follow-up
questions was yes if you weren't wearing
LeBrons would you have fallen I think so
I think if I was wearing my dress shoes
I would I would have busted my ass
because that side line right there even
in pregame you got hit so hard yeah I
thought the last s fell off your name
but no it was so muddy over there though
in the pregame Lefko they literally the
Kansas City ground crew had to come and
dump like more grass and wood on there
to basically drop because it was like
divots like this big from mud um that
was it I did I was semi embarrassed so
then my next question was you see the
video did you then get angry that you
apologized and he said at least you know
you're an [ __ ] no no I never got
anything wrong
i I he's he's not really in the wrong
I'm in the wrong why cuz I it's it's his
turf I gotta get out of the way
technically I'm supposed to be even off
where I was it should have been high the
white dotted line so this was all my
fault I have nothing I didn't appreciate
his attitude towards me but you but he's
doing his job and I get it but yes I got
so many text messages any from any of
her that we're surprising or really
funny like my my ex strength coach in
Tennessee yeah there's some Watterson he
was like he was the best he's like oh
you better tell that ref he doesn't know
who he's messing with
he better watch out you know he was
telling cuz you say you could tell that
you're saying sorry yeah I thought that
you turned around like you were gonna
throw them hands no no I wasn't I was
like mad at myself I was like little
skip man I did that he had a nice little
skip gathered it you know I mean I could
take a shot in the market if you would
have fallen oh I would have been and I
would have been worse we would have done
the hunter show I'm sure
I might have not shown up today so his
his jersey was BB the refs the ref was
BB BB let me say oh no you say like Bill
Belichick texted you my bad no but do we
know the number yet of the guy did Josh
look on video no hasn't been able to
find it yet but I'm almost positive it's
that guy damn weather would I have to go
back and look you don't know where the
video is Josh just looking for it I'll
need you to focus okay
because I took the video yeah and I put
it on my Instagram right and I said Sims
got hit so hard
blank right and I got hundreds of
responses so Nick if you're ready one
more time it is time for the top ten
responses to our Sims got hit so hard
fill in the blank contest and we're
gonna start off with number 10 Sims was
hit so hard to stop button is now in the
eighth row at Arrowhead number nine Sims
got hit so hard his spleen popped back
into existence
number eight Sims got hit so hard he
thought Blake bortles was the 69th best
quarterback in Popoff for that's number
seven Sims got hit so hard Philip asked
him to buy him a ref jersey number six
Sims got hit so hard he forgot about
global warming for a second ever never
would forget that number five Sims got
hit so hard he had to go to the locker
room for a daddy cigar Tim's got it so
hard his rifle rice and beans came out
the tuner number three's choking the
number three Sims got hit so hard his
ancestors in Kentucky all flinch
number two Sims got hit so hard he got
out Baltimore in Arrowhead Sims got hit
so hard that the new name of the show
should be refs and let it go and that is
the top 10 responses to hard Sims got
hit by the refs
brought to you by the rest for America
if you keep saying we suck
we'll hit your ass on the sidelines
really seriously thank you to these
people for their submissions awesome job
Nikki G awesome Josh Ron 23 nerds and
needles tattoo
Martinez J Jack Emma Schneider Hugo
it's Felder Michael Felder Oh Felder got
in there he got in there too I think he
was his race of beams came on the tutor
but I can't confirm our nav we t Fox 66
and PJ Mazzoni and thank you to the
hundreds of other people that clown don
said thank you thank you thank you
everybody is so nice how are the bruises
they're good I'm fine I mean I'm a
soldier man it can't hurt me like that
come on come on LeBron soldiers yes
let's stay with that game yeah you I'm
watching the pregame show yeah and at
one point you said hey guys I'm just
being just telling you what I see luck
isn't throwing of that great and my
homes is throwing it really well I I
wish that more TV broadcasters when
they're at a game gave us observations
what makes someone like you and football
or like a Berkeley and basketball is you
guys see things that we wouldn't even
know what to look for
like I'm gonna admit something to you
right now yeah remember when we saw
Amari Cooper at training camp and you
looked at me and said holy [ __ ] and I
was like unbelievable I didn't know what
the [ __ ] was happening I mean he looked
fast right but I was going off you
looking at me going damn yeah your
ability to watch people in warm-ups is a
strength what did you see even before
the game yeah I mean Andrew Luck came
out I don't want to sit here and make it
sound like he was a clown or anything he
certainly was throwing it good but you
know it started out just him throwing to
receiver stationary targets and it
looked yeah it looked okay but then when
they started to get you know alright
let's start throwing some routes and
some seven-on-seven and things like that
you know again completing all these
passes but the quality of the football
was a little concerning I was gonna move
that ball could have fluttered it in the
air there like that's not gonna work
when it's third and seven in the crowds
loud and guys are flying around to me
it's the equivalent of being at the
racetrack and the guy that waits to see
the horses before he goes to the window
right like I almost want to wait the
next time you get to be on the field and
be like you govern that yeah well yes
how much is it is it like almost all the
time if you throw well in warm-ups
you're gonna throw a well in the game if
you don't throw a while where I'm sure
not gonna not always it's not always
that way but I big thing here was the
elements right and it was windy and it
was it was these big snowflakes that
were making the ball wet so it wasn't
going to be like you
no oh you're just gonna be able to put
the ball on the ground cause of snow the
ball won't get that wet right so it was
those things that I was more worried
about you know quarterbacks can go
through warm-ups and you go it wasn't
the best I've ever seen then throw the
ball and they come out in the game
starts and they throw rifles everywhere
but this was something where I know the
quarterbacks we're gonna be you know
extra on their game and pregame warmups
because you are going what can I get
away with in the elements what you know
how hard do I have to throw it going in
this direction do I have to play the
wind when I throw a comeback on this
sideline because the wind might blow the
ball two or three feet one way whatever
it may be and yeah Luck's footballs
certainly fluttered a little bit so I
was there by him for the majority of
warm-ups and kind of watching my home to
her in distance and then I had a break
in action for what I had to do and I
kind of started to walk that way a
little bit just to go let me get a
little closer to Kansas City and we just
see a few balls and see my homes throw
it and then the first throw he threw
that I really was there to watch and
study I mean that ball cut through the
wind and was spinning so hard I went
whoa I don't think he's gonna have any
issues out here and then the next throw
and I went holy crap this is
unbelievable I felt like I was watching
Aaron Rodgers again warm up and which is
I haven't had this feeling in a long
time it was a life changing it is for
you when you saw Aaron Rodgers throw
yeah talk about that all the time it is
all my dad too
right my dad as well right this was
similar it was similar cuz I was just
like oh hey well is it was about just
the same except it's just like a
different way because he's just so loose
and relaxed and how he does it and
everything but same feeling of just
going whoa that's a different quality of
football and holy cow he has to put no
effort into it and he throws it
forty-five yards and a line into the
wind with snow and it's just like right
in the guy's hand and right then I was
like uh-oh this this is not gonna affect
Kansas City today they're gonna be okay
as long as Tyree kill doesn't slip a lot
or Sammy walk and slip then mahomes is
gonna be able to throw if he's got time
and of course he he delivered what was
like to see Tyreke he'll run and yeah
amazing that's what I that's what
happened to me on that play I became fan
boy I was watching Tyreke but watching
his legs go feel just his turnover
unbelievable he's such a ball of muscle
that's the first thing you'll notice
when he run on the field it's just
there's no body fat I mean it is just as
dense and thick as you could possibly be
smashed into a what does he if what does
he 510 yeah yeah about that so so
impressive and really as soon as the
game started you know Kansas City
I thought jumped off the screen to just
where you were like all right one team
looks like they're playing them fast
forward and the other team looks like
it's like you know exactly right and
Kansas City was the energized team
rested and ready to go yeah well the
game went exactly how we thought Kansas
City jumping out to a 24-7 yeah and
there were a lot of opportunities for
the Colts to get back in the game
definitely they just blew all of them
there was a Darius Leonard forced fumble
which was an absolute game changer and
then Aaron Andrew Luck fumbled it right
back right Andrew had a lot of
opportunities in Kansas City zone to
make it that one possession game yeah
and the offense couldn't capitalize that
was the big shocker was the Colts
offensive line had zero success they
lost the battle it wasn't it wasn't even
they didn't dominate them enough yeah
they got dominated yeah first time I
think we could say that really since
maybe early in the year all the
favorites won this weekend yeah all the
home teams won this weekend right
and they looked rested yes they looked
strong they did did you notice that I er
what what happened with the OL I totally
did
totally notice that and it you know I
think like we've talked about this a lot
like Mort about Super Bowl matchup so
when like a good defense has to play
great quarterback and the defensive line
here's all week like if you want to win
this game Strahan and talking you want
to be Brady and then defeat him you guys
gonna have to win it I felt like this
was a very similar thing where these
monsters of the Kansas City Dean line
and Houston D Ford Chris Jones all week
how to hear about the Colts and of
course they had the week before that
where they got to prepare for the Colts
a little bit too I'm sure they allotted
a few days to them to where guess they
were geared up ready to go to answer the
challenge and they knew that of course
that her secondary was vulnerable
against luck in the passing game and
they did they took over from get-go I
mean we saw Quentin Nelson get pushed
back a number of times like Chris Jones
10 knocking balls down you know that was
a big aspect of the game and then luck
you know I thought luck he did what you
know what you can't do an element's
sometimes he tried to place the ball I
thought like let me just say he's aiming
for your your chest right let me just
place it under your chest and in
elements like this you have to throw it
through the target you have to go I'm
going to throw it through his chest
right because if you try to place it
wind hits it and all sudden it dies down
or whatever you have to be willing to go
I have to throw the ball through the
target not exactly hit the target ah
it's a punch shot right exactly right
something like that right and I thought
they blew some opportunities with some
easy completions early on and him being
off their old line getting you know beat
up but more than not what we worried
about on Thursday and Wednesday when we
talked about it
the Colts secondary is not that talented
they've never seen as high-octane pass
offense the whole gear show and they
were overmatched right uh Chiefs with
Sammy Watkins yes look out there like
first of all another guy that pops just
when you watch and warm up because he's
different looking
you know he's different looking in the
fact that you know I'm gonna say what
Sammy six one maybe six one and a half
you know long arms great-looking legs
and ass right great muscle definition
once again you know he looks like an
upper echelon receiver and to me that is
a big key and it was great that they
kind of got him involved early on right
left go with you know this is what we
want to say I'm sorry shallow crosser
underneath right Hill was deep Kelsey
was in the middle here came play the
first game against the Patriots um yes
he did he did you know I want to say you
had a few catches in that game but
nothing nothing groundbreaking Kelsey is
a dog a dog like for someone that I find
to be so good on camera and LA and know
how to do clothes and fashion and he's
like really popular I've never seen
someone like that enjoy contact so much
usually they're pretty boys right and he
could just handle anybody Chiefs
offensive line is super underrated yes
it is and can we finally stop asking is
the moment gonna be too big for Patrick
mahomes I mean come on it's not no
nothing is nothing
he's nothing it just goes back to our
old like
you know the guys who are super talented
they can just go out and have fun and
laugh and like the this they're never
under pressure because they just feel
like okay I'm really good and I belong
and there's nothing that can go on out
here that I don't feel like I can
overcome and yes his presence of mind
his poise it jumps out as soon as he
runs on the field for pregame just the
whole stadium goes electric you could
tell he's unfazed about it he brings it
on a little bit he just has a credible
you know aura about him and Andrew Luck
has an aura but it's not like Patrick
mahomes and especially when the game
starts you know mahomes is just a
special talent where you could even
notice you know again I always look at
like the sideline for little things like
that like they're there watching Patrick
mahomes the defense the guys in the
bench cuz they're just like damn this
guy's out here like we gotta watch what
they touch them yeah I think yeah I
didn't see anybody touch right if you're
on the bench and you're getting touched
people maybe you're right um but I
thought you know the thing with all
these games is a really good offensive
coach yeah had an extra week to prepare
and he knew exactly where to attack in
the defense and Andy Reed after a buy is
notoriously phenomenal and I have to
imagine my confidence of the Chiefs is
sky-high right now sure but do you
believe that defensive performers can
continue or is that just because I mean
if they can get pressure on the Colts
offensive line at home yes I do think
that that I mean this is a different
animal they coming into town this week
as much as we love Frank Reich and
Andrew Luck and everything they do on
the offensive side of the ball this will
be a much more tactical response than
even what they had to this Kansas City
defense and yes there's just there's
just more styles of play that the
Patriots can bring to the table then
maybe a team like the Colts and the big
thing is it's kind of what we saw
yesterday the Patriots they want to run
the ball down hill but they have a
million things to do off of it as well
that really puts you in a bind you
really do have the offense that's made
to beat up the Chiefs yes is play-action
right pound the ball exactly just really
what you need and the Colts were never
in a situation to establish the run they
tried to keep trying Mac right but it
and they didn't do anything creative for
naheem Heinz and let's be honest I mean
that was the reason that Detroit fans
were okay with Ebron and being gone yeah
drops like that no doubt about it they
were crucial drops yeah they were bit
when you're getting your ass kicked in
the first half you need first downs
right you need to help out that defense
but Colts phenomenal year uh nominal
like they are they have the most salary
cap in the NFL they have Andrew Luck on
a somewhat reasonable contract for a guy
of his stature right they have an
offensive line built for the next few
years they have a few pieces on the
defense that are really coming together
and I mentioned the free agency they
could make some big splashes and they
have a coach that you got to believe in
yes and a GM yes it's all it's all going
in the right direction for the Colts and
I think another element that we probably
needed to bring up for the game that
hurt the Colts sty Hilton was not a
hundred percent you know you could tell
early on that even when I saw him
jogging he was jogging a little bit with
like a limp he could certainly see it
and I think his show displayed a little
bit too he just wasn't an explosive as
we used to say to make this a wide
receiver ranking thing but that's what
always makes it hard for me to put the
AJ greens and the T Y Hilton's up high
yeah is there just guys that met like
Sammy Watkins I just can't put them up
that high sure cuz their availability is
so into questions every week yeah I get
that it's a real questions and I think
we also have to give credit to Andy Reid
for running in the football just enough
I mean that's not like Andy Reid but he
ran it consistently through the game to
where the Colts could never just go oh
it's passed let's pass rush and play
pass defense and that was great to see
and I hope he can continue they don't
have to break the wrecking rush or ruck
rushing record or anything like that
they just need to run just enough to
where the defense has to respect that
the defensive play caller has to respect
it to open up everything one thing I
noticed just in watching it on TV - I
felt like mahomes lined up under center
more in the game than he has all year
and it's something that I've asked them
to do on the podcast before because I
think it will bring in play-action pass
and open up more of the deep shots that
they're looking for in the pass game
every time I saw Damien Williams put his
foot in the ground and turn upfield I
went this is hurting the value of the
running back
position right when I when I want
Anderson to CJ Anderson and James Conner
I want levy on bail to get paid right
but the problem is is it so easy to find
these guys
no and it's it really is all about the
offensive line that's it's a support
system just like anything is I mean
who's all running like Adrian Peterson
and say Kwan our running backs that make
up for their team
yes but there's a lot of team there's a
lot of guys that have kind of it's the
number one knock that people give
towards Emmitt Smith and I don't think
it's warranted but I understand it yeah
and then you look at Barry Sanders ago
and we're gonna turn to know but I I
mean I get you you don't listen
again it's not gonna make me devalue
Todd Gurley cuz CAJ Anderson was there
okay yeah great that was a great
performance he did really well trust me
if the game went on and the year went on
and we still had the same combo the
separation would just you know
differentiate itself to where you'd go
Gurley is clearly the better player I've
heard that Belichick Wright was more
obsessed with having healthy running
backs than good running backs was all I
needed to know yeah Todd Gurley can last
an entire season I mean I know he got
banged up lately but he can be excellent
for 15 games CJ's gonna give you one or
two and that's the difference between
those two guys but I've also realized if
I'm playing FanDuel or something like
that after the Patriots I want a guy
that didn't go off last week like
whichever running about like I don't
think so D Michelle's gonna have the
same game he did next week that he did
this week yeah because he's obsessed
with rotations because he wants guys
that are a hundred and ten percent sure
because the offensive lines gonna make
their blocks you gotta hit the hole sure
Cowboys Rams
yep Saturday night awesome bet by you
kid
and then he's awesome I mean I I you
know of course depict the Rams to win I
never would have looked cheap sort of
one by eighteen I wouldn't expect to
that right and I wouldn't know I knew we
just thought luck can make the common
yeah you're exactly right
you're right and then the yeah I know
the Cowboys Rams is gonna be like last
Drive of the game type of thing which it
was through a degree but not the way I
envisioned it
Rams controlled that game yes hi every
time they did the story that came out is
that they were able to look at the the
placement and this the the splits of the
Dallas defense and the Rams knew all
their stunts
if woods or Collins went a little bit
wider they're doing a stunt have you
ever heard of that before did it make
sense now afterwards well it made sense
because as I was watching the game and
then they were like you know
Aikman a buck would show the replays I
was going late like that play they ran
they're like there's no way Dallas can
stop that in that alignment that was my
first inkling to go something's up here
they got a bead on something because
it's more milk in that full 15 right it
was it's one thing to go okay here's a
good run play and we you know we
actually just physically manhandled
somebody but I was seeing replays
schematically going wait there's no way
they can line up in that defense to stop
this play they're totally screwed and
that was like oh the Rams have a bead on
something in their defense and then I
read the story and hear all the quotes
from the Rams players saying they have a
beat on yes at the the three technique
was a little wider
that meant he might stunt with the
defensive end and people are talking
about it like they stole hand signals no
I don't think it was not a lineman thing
I think what they mean by hand signals
is like if your fingers were a certain
way or your hand is right hand was down
he was rushing his left hand was down he
might have been going looping behind the
defensive end and this is the second
week in a row we've heard something like
this the first one
Dallas used it to their advantage wasn't
it wasn't Seattle's offensive line they
said they could tell with like pulling
guards and things like that right by
thinking of the right team I feel like
that was part of it right wasn't in
Seattle are we missing it missing
something there's a left tackle
well that was Russell oak on let's say
who are the other teams Tennessee oh you
might you're talking about the Ravens
Chargers game I think you're right I
think Avani standby Ronnie Stanley in
Orlando Brown but this is this is
something where if fans can figure it
out on Twitter and coaches can game plan
it for in the future this is why you
have to self Scout yeah if you don't
like because teams have people that
watch their own film and try and find
week
right I mean you have to self scout I
mean that's why New England is New
England that's why any good team is you
know Shaun McVeigh I'm sure he pays
attention to okay if I have three
receivers to the right man 90% of the
time those are those receivers go out so
I got to start making some place to
where they go in have you ever looked at
defensive line placement or which hand
was down yeah definitely definitely I
would be something Gruden like Gruden
would tell us first of all break when
you break the huddle the first thing you
look at is the defense in front because
the defensive front is going to give you
the clues to what they can do from that
front the blitzes they might bring the
stunts the slants or whatever
now this seemed more like they truly had
not only just the alignment down but
they could tell what they were gonna try
to do at the snap of the ball and my
mind went here when I first read those
quotes it's the first thing I thought of
Rod Marinelli defensive coordinator for
the Dallas Cowboys earth to Tampa Bay
worked and Rodman ml Rod Marinelli
son-in-law is Joe Barry the defense
linebacker coach for the Rams and what
yes Wendy this has been for like the
Steelers are washing on rod Marin and
when I was okay Joe Barry was in before
this he's been at USC he was with the
Chargers as well Chargers right you're
probably because he was with Gus Bradley
the the linebacker coach for the Rams oh
very fun in-law of the defensive
coordinator of the cow big exactly right
and I thought right away I wonder if Joe
like knew okay I've hit Joe Joe and rod
were in Tampa together they go way way
back and I just thought I wonder if he
knew after like the offense might have
came over to Joe Barry said hey Joe you
know when they line up like you know
whatever he might again like oh they're
gonna run that the tackle and stunts or
you know the tackle tackle loop game
whatever it may be and that's just where
my mind when I don't know that but I
just those are things that look for when
we did at Longwood Aaron Cromer as the
o-line coach who was also in Tampa with
me when Rod Marinelli was there so there
was a lot of common things there he's
right I know when we were doing Atlanta
New York
this year New York was down 15 remember
the everyone's saying you should always
go 4-2 when you're down 15 giving you
more percentage chance remember that
right how hard were you rooting for the
Cowboys to go 4-2 to cover the seven not
a realistic thought right you always as
a gambler I was like please kick the
extra point
oh no but see you have to you have to
continue to keep the pressure on the
other team and let the game play out and
then so you kick the extra point because
you make it a one score game if you make
it miss it I've read Pepe car just to
score game read papers where it's
actually that you're hiding the truth
for yourself I've read papers where it
says if you're doubt you don't know if
you're gonna get that last two so if you
know that you mess it up and let's say
you get the ball back and it's fourth
fourth and nine at the 30 since you know
that you've already missed it you can
keep the field goal there you know what
I mean yeah but you're worse if you
don't know but you might know you know
you're gonna hit the ball one more time
so you can't risk that and then go oh
damn now we need the ball another time
to go buy it down by two this
conversation well because I'm right and
anybody else there that out there I'm
just telling you I'm right don't even
waste your time trying to argue this
point nobody is going to you have to I
hate that you have to kick the extra
point to make the other team play and
deal with the situation that's all there
is to it I my analysis of the game
beforehand was I think Shawn McVeigh is
gonna do what we've always wanted people
to do against Dallas side to side and
use their aggression against them I
couldn't believe that van Dhiresh was on
the sidelines like what he looked
shocked he looks stunned like what
happened I I mean I'll be excited to
watch the film but yes there is so many
plays where he is so blocked or so
pushed out of the way are so not in the
play I think he got overwhelmed and his
first experience by rules and motions
and oh no they told me to keep this and
they're doing this and that and I can't
key it all and the rookie showed up let
alone them having a beat on their
running game let it alone I'm just
telling you I still van der ish as a
freak athlete I need to see him run up
into holes and fill holes that's what I
wanna
he's been winning with athleticism
always but when the run comes right Adam
and things like that there is a weakness
there and that was what I worried about
them in the draft but this is something
I got a watch and I'll give you a really
good answer on Wednesday and when we do
the breakdown of the film exactly what
happened to wildest thing about the NFL
is that when you're really afraid of
somebody yeah the number one thing you
can do is run right at them right oh von
miller is too good run out of right Oh
Leighton man Irish oh Bosa and Ingram
he's gonna run at him right isn't that
interesting yeah every other sport you
avoid yeah NFL to deal with their great
athleticism give them a job at home yeah
give them just given there's no
athleticism involved now it becomes
about power strength can you disengage
from the block or all of those things
where of course the Rams felt like they
had an advantage and so did the Patriots
with Bose on Ingram Goff yeah there's
nothing special yak
yeah again you know I mean it sounds
like the Cowboys you're gonna keep
Scotland a hand that's it's all reports
are pointing that way I would still
argue that they need more in their task
game for just reasons we saw the other
night
Cowboys getting rid of Scott or should
get more people to me like when I heard
the Ravens got rid of Marty mourning
Wegg I said I'm glad that they can be
honest with themselves there's just some
coordinators in this league that they've
been doing it one way for so long that
they've never changed and Scott Linehan
softens has been the same thing now for
like five years yeah I do
and listen if they want to keep Scott
Lenihan and Jason Garrett then they just
need to they need to either get new
ideas in the building yes they listed it
with Chris Rashard let's do the same
thing bring in a cat passing game
coordinator or somebody that could just
infuse just another cut few concepts it
doesn't take a lot we saw they got to
the divisional playoff game if they
could just add another 15 to 20 pages of
the rolodex
it could change their football team are
you confident when Cooper took that one
of the house I was not I can't say that
I was like I wasn't sitting there going
I don't jump on anything too early
because I've been there before where
I've been on the drive in the first game
and goddamn we went right down on that
team and they're they're in trouble
today and then awesome we don't move the
ball the rest of the game so I'm always
quick to be go to crazy
like jumping up 14
not score at a point through right
you've been there before but would you
think what teo coming out after the game
and saying Jason Garrett should be fired
everyone's gonna look at Jason Garrett I
understand the phrase the frustrations
with Jason Garrett certainly and you
know again at this point in time you
know I wouldn't sit here and just go oh
Dallas is crazy if they decide to end
the relationship with Jason Jason
Garrett I get it I get it but I would
also say Jason Garrett is better than a
lot of coaches that are out there as
well how did the Rams stop Zeke from
what you saw yeah to me it just looked
like they what I would say and this is
gonna be a Joe Barry term you know they
were definitely more sound and staying
in their gaps right Aaron Donnell didn't
look like he freelanced a whole lot
didn't look like sue freelanced a whole
lot and it looked like to me the second
level something that they would use in
that defensive terminology shot their
gun
that's a Joe Barry I would say shoot
your gun like if you're responsible for
the gap between the guard and the tackle
and you see a hole open up and they're
running backs running they're go run
through it and shoot your gun and that's
what I it looked like to me what
happened there they played discipline
and because they play discipline you
know double-team box had a stay on Aaron
Donald the old line wasn't as free just
to fly up to the second level and
because of that discipline holes opened
up and the linebackers at the second
level for the Rams Baron Littleton those
guys Littleton he thinketh fly they can
fly he can fly so if he's got nobody on
him and he can just stay in his gap and
their ball goes into his gap he will
beat the running back to that gap it was
pretty remarkable how much that defense
changed went to leave one else yeah when
to leave went out it was like it was
though like Marcus Peters now was like
the number one guy and they attacked him
am i right
but to leave I'm glad to leave came yeah
it should be good to go it seems like
and yeah I'm gonna be interested to see
how they played them coverage wise
throughout the game certainly saw man
but like we've been talking about that
Rams played more zone down the stretch
than man coverage but they need both of
them to be at full strength certainly
against the Saints I still think they're
gonna be a zone football team but you
just need those few plays like we always
talked about
game if you're a zone team to match up
and play man-to-man on a third and four
so drew brees can't find a little hole
and then just stick it in there I just
want to say a big hearty left go thank
you to Shawn McVeigh for going for it on
fourth and goal on the one to get the
touchdown to ice the eight-point win
yeah because if he kicks that field goal
he's fearless and the Cowboys drive down
and they win by four yeah and you
destroyed me in the bets not gonna
handle it
what is art I mean a my way out of it
can I even make a comeback I probably
better come back well if it's only
mortality aim if you and me bet big
difference on these games yeah I don't
know I'll give you the official I didn't
look it up yeah I just know I had the
big swing oh of course you did I know I
mean good
thank God the for that thank God the
Eagles covered last night because that
would have been really screwed well you
wouldn't oh it's on the computer I don't
want to look at it I'm gonna look at I
want to look at that Thursday and I want
to see the numbers now all right um what
about Zach Taylor officially gonna be
the Bengals head coach it looks like
yeah what do you think I mean I think
it's the same craziness of LeFleur and
Kingsbury it's just like not premature
like way too premature like
ridiculousness like I'm more ridiculous
cliff or Zach I lift Arizona or Zach
Taylor's I would say Zach yeah and again
like I'm gonna throws a can the same
things I said about the other two always
thought he had potential to be a head
coach no wet they're not doing the
offensive game plan in Los Angeles
there's one guy doing that and that's
kid genius he's the only one doing it
and then he's going in there and going
hey guys I want to do this this week I
want to do that this week and hey do you
guys have a few ideas to throw in here
and then that's what they're doing so
now they're gonna be responsible for a
whole game plan and coming up with
different things on a weekly basis oh
and you're gonna coach the rest of the
football team and be in charge of you
know discipline and guys call it in you
know my my wife's about to have a baby
or I gotta leave because my mother died
or whatever but you have to deal with
all these other things now to me yes
it's way too early and I
his insanity at this point you mean like
as a leader of men yeah I mean and he is
capable of that but it's just there's so
many curveballs thrown to you on a daily
basis as a head coach you know it's not
just like everything doesn't go perfect
in there's a whole bunch of coaches you
got to worry about there the front
office is bringing people in to work out
you got injuries you're trying to make
you know roster changes and sign free
agents and all that and you're not
always afford to the luxury to go oh I
can sit here for you know nine hours and
and break down a game and really get my
game plan in order and that's where I
push back against Zach Taylor always
thought he was head coach material just
again I think it's too early and I think
a lot of these owners and GM's it's just
showing how clueless they are I mean you
know I just I don't you know they're
clueless they're just looking at an idea
and running with it
young young coach offense a genius Oh
sold sold I'll take it I'll take it yeah
I'll take it
great but like we said there the other
ones that worked out had tremendous
results before they got those jobs I
have hot news whoa right off the press
give me a close I'll even tell me yet
clue me Declaration of Independence
somewhat okay declaration can I have
another word you said one okay okay give
me two words draft okay somebody's
coming out in the draft who's the only
one that matters
Oh calimary Kyler Murray has come weird
for the NFL Draft
it's so funny we were just talking about
it what do you think and like you said
you said if he's thinking about it and
wants 15 million that means he really
wants to go it's it's I heard it was on
the Bill Simmons interview with Adam
McKay and his last year with SNL he was
like I'm done and his agent goes if you
know you're done ask for something
ridiculous because maybe they'll give it
to you right and he asked for it they
gave it to him Wow
that's what Kyle married Cuyler Murray
just yeah he goes gimme 20 mil give me
15 minutes protecting himself I get it
you know because if you're drafted in
the first round you're gonna get
somewhere within the 15 million
guaranteed range so be so yeah yes he's
gonna get booed but he wasn't gonna go
FLT wasn't gonna go oh okay yeah I'll
leave 11 million dollars on the table
and go play baseball when everybody's
telling him he's gonna be a first-round
pick in the NFL so he was right to play
as a businessman because that's what he
is now to say wait this doesn't make
sense
baseball guys if you want me to come
play I'm being 15 million told here in
this corner and you guys are giving me
four so why would I go do that when I
have an 11 million difference and it
seemed like his heart was on football
too I hope you guys were runny because
for the next three and a half months
we'll ask can he make it as the prune
size matter oh my gosh it's he is he is
of I I think that if he didn't declare
this was gonna be a Haskins draft where
we look at his one year at Ohio State
and we just pour over that film and it
becomes like Mitchell true Biscay yeah
where we just go he's one year enough
that's all he's done Kyler Murray is
going to be the most interesting man the
NFL Draft he will be discussed and poked
and prodded all Baker Mayfield we're
gonna hear him a lot in the news
Kliff Kingsbury going to Arizona really
a puts Josh Rosen into a really
uncomfortable situation after those
comments surfaced on camera
yeah of Kliff Kingsbury saying I take
him as the number one pick yeah then
they had to come out and deny that they
were shopping Josh Rosen yeah
would you take Josh Rosen hurt Kyler
Murray just as this as a as your future
of the franchise I'd probably take
calimary
Wow I know scary it's crazy do it like
what do you think about like the whole
like all IV work I mean and say I got
Josh Rosen for your six or have you
think that's something you think that
blows you away and that's been fine but
if you're just gonna trade them away
then you're stupid and then maybe Steve
kinda needs to be fired for drafting the
guy that you're gonna but I just can't
imagine that that would be a real
possibility unless they found a team
that was legitimately willing to give up
I don't know a high second-round or
something like that for a Josh rosy
hammy yeah New York Jacksonville if
they're interested yeah if they're
interested because they might also be
sitting there going no you stay with him
we'll take
Kyler's 'it's yeah I can't see the New
York Giants ever thinking about a guy
like calimary they're like New England
they want like I'm just saying yeah
Kyler's say Quan Odell oh my gosh
seriously that would be sick Kyler in
Jacksonville will be fun
it would be that would be a lot of fun
he'd be perfect for that what they want
to do what is your super early haven't
even went back and watched game film
only TV copy view of calimary as a pro
pro I mean I
I'll say I aligned with everybody else
I'm thinking that I thought he was a
first round talent for sure yes I mean
his arm is first round talent his
athleticism of course his first round
talent you know it's gonna be about you
know the little things again just
finding games to where he did struggle
what made him struggle are there any
throws he couldn't see your maker but
you know like I said last week when
Baker Mayfield like waxes poetically
about you the way he did with Kyler
Murray that tells me it's pretty legit
and what my eye is seen on TV has
thought it's pretty legit as well so the
only other breaking news that I'll have
is your boy Adam GaSe has becoming a
meme Eddie yeah oh because he had his
press conference today yeah yeah what do
you think happened at this press
conference that's me beable uh either
rolled his eyes pulled his hat down
really low or said a swear so the second
one is not possible because he didn't
wear a hat okay but you were kind of
right about the eyes because his eyes
have become an internet meme because
Adam GaSe kind of has crazy eyes he does
yeah he Adam GaSe kind of has those eyes
that bulge out a little bit yeah there's
a reason he wears his hat super low it's
like if you have a zit on your forehead
yeah he's intense there's no doubt about
that and he's no-nonsense and yeah those
eyes can make the player get the willies
and go damn he's he's looking through in
my soul I better start playing better
cuz he seems like he wants to cut me on
the spot let's get to the sunday games
now that was our breaking news
intermission declaration I love how he
gave me that declaration Chargers
Patriots was the most disappointing game
of
for yeah I thought yeah it was I was not
a game I put I put a few hundred dollars
on the under and in the under and the
Patriots winning and the Patriots Pratt
I think covered the over/under by
themselves right and I'm so dumb yeah
it's just it's Tom Brady and Josh
McDaniels versus the Seattle scheme
defense exactly they taught us the
blueprint in the Superbowl
that's right underneath James White
underneath to Edelman right and whitely
ends up with like 1415 catches and sony
Michelle
like when I hear national people like
when I hear like the Bill Simmons of the
world or all these people say that they
doubted the Patriots or that they didn't
think Sony Michelle was gonna be good I
just don't understand how they could
ever feel that with the only people that
are doubting New England just so we get
this clear right now without a doubt
it's the only people I actually have to
stick up to New England for like when
you do when I do most when I go on
regional sports and NBC nobody is more
negative about New England than that
Channel right there so Tom Brady is
really only hearing this vacuum of
people saying they suck by his own
because he's watching the local his
wife's watching the local news and he's
hearing it and that it's his own fan
base mommy can't even throw the ball to
the flag what something's got to be
wrong something's got to be wrong on it
all yeah exactly that's exactly
III really believe though that they need
to find all of the people in the last
year or two even three where people said
that the Patriots dynasty was over and I
feel like those people should be
suspended for like they shouldn't be
allowed to cover the Super Bowl yeah I
really believe yeah well I hear you like
we've been saying it the whole time like
anyone that says that don't listen and
yet you shouldn't be allowed to talk
anymore yeah when you're that wrong
about something that's that consistent
eight straight is it nine straight AFC
championships nay this is eight eight
yeah it's insane what's insane I mean
it's Bill Russell did this when there
were like 10 teams in the NBA right John
Wooden did it when there was like 16
teams in the NCAA tournament this is
it's LeBron and Tom Brady yeah
every year they do something that should
not be happening in this day and age
it's unreal it's the greatest this is
the greatest dynasty I've ever seen I
would say it's better than any of the
dynasties we've ever seen if you went to
Bill Belichick and said hey Bill
the Rams looked at the Cowboys defensive
alignments that was able to figure out
what they were doing I feel like Bill
would go and yeah yeah there's one of
that's one of the 18 things I hate it
like no [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah why did the
charger stay in that defense the whole
game because that's that's the Seattle
scheme and that's what they do and why
did they stay with seven defense by
we've complained all year or all the
last three to four years not the
Chargers yeah about these schemes in
general that when they have to play
really good offenses with a scheme and a
quarterback that's able to execute the
scheme they get to one apart it doesn't
matter 49ers versus axon ville last year
you know this game whatever see yeah you
know we could go through it no matter
what Ben Roethlisberger in Seattle two
years ago when he threw for 460 yards
it's to this day and age that defense is
too common around the NFL and it's just
plain old stupid to line up in the same
defense all game long against the great
quarterbacks and the great offense is a
football because they're just you're in
the comfort zone the whole game they're
going oh yeah yeah okay this one oh this
one okay yeah we have like let's see
okay so here's this is where we start
right first of all we know and you know
I've been saying this a lot lately every
team in football has got their
kryptonite in the NFL I don't care who
you are you're gonna run into your
kryptonite at some point and what's
amazing about New England is they can
run into their kryptonite but Bill can
out think you an out game plan for you
to lessen the the strength of the
kryptonite and then all of a sudden you
go damn they still won even though they
were their kryptonite that's what's
amazing about New England but you know
okay
the New England Patriots won have had
two Super Bowls verse this scheme right
Dave right so that's two weeks of Super
Bowl preparation now just which for Bill
Belichick is like diving into like Dan
Quinn's middle school like church choir
right and going you know
sometimes he touches his nose when he
gets nervous I noticed that in the
spelling bee when he was eight right so
and that and he doesn't throw it away
like there's a lot of people that work
at companies that are like good job
everybody and then like we don't learn
anything Bill's like I'll never forget
that information right ever has filed
away they know everything and like you
said Super Bowl is another level this is
not by week in the middle of the NFL
preparation where everybody leaves Super
Bowl the players are still there
practicing the coaches are doing like
insane hours all week long before the
Super Bowl or two weeks before the Super
Bowl let alone the week of the Super
Bowl and literally like you said are
picking apart things about like how long
their fingernails were in ninth grade
but so that's the first thing the the
the common knowledge of that defense out
of the fact the size problem for the
Chargers came back to get him find it
you thought it was gonna happen kind of
against the Ravens yep and it did the
first time yep but what was it about
what the Patriots did that was more
effective than with the Ravens so the
Patriots have more run schemes like we
talked about last week the Patriots have
nine million play-action passes like we
saw yesterday once again right and Tom's
at a point of his career when he sells
it oh I played oh I think I'm watching
at home well and that's where it started
I mean they started running the ball
right away so when they started running
the ball you're like oh yeah this is
trouble they got them they're not only
physically beating him but they got the
right runs called for the right
situations and then going back to what
we talked about with the Rams and the
Cowboys the Chargers Joe Barry came from
this scheme the Chargers Gus Bradley was
in Tampa with me with Rod Marinelli and
all these people they believe in the
shoot your gun theory right so they know
they're small at the second level you
see the hole fly up it and early on
remember they made a few runs where they
tackled them three or four yards we have
the line of scrimmage yes because like
Derwin James or somebody sees the hole
and they don't wait for anything else
they just go I'm going and that's how
they coach it and then play-action
Patriots right so then you start to run
the ball and do have a little success
and play-action nobody's better exposing
the second level of the defense than New
England Patriots I mean first of all I
don't think Brady threw a ball over five
yards until 12 min
left in the second quarter when he threw
a laser down the middle to Edelman I
don't think there was one ball over five
yards to that point so that just shows
you the preparation that game plan was
just an absolute ass whoopin right off
the bat there okay so that would be my
two cents on that side of the ball the
other side of the ball I mean kind of
went what we said - we worried about the
Chargers receivers speed right they
didn't they couldn't get away from
anybody couldn't except on the one
Keenan Allen which was a double move
right where he got stuff on Gilmore in a
little curl and go right
other than that they got in their face
played man to man said you can't run by
us they put pressure on Phillip Rivers
why cuz he can't run at all at all so
that's an issue and they said that's our
strength and let's make it their flaw
and they went after him and then the
Chargers kept just beating their head
him we're gonna throw it deep we're
gonna throw a deep do you have a pick
play do you have shallow crossers that
can cross each other and pick each other
it was quickly lost to Mike Williams
that's the whole time and that that I
didn't get but how do you think
Belichick neutralized Ingram and Bosa
because of first of all how did Trent
Brown do from what you saw against the
speed guy that you were a little worried
of yeah definitely well the run game
they'd let him come off on the run game
and then once Ingram Bosa could never
really tee off and they'd go oh gosh
like I can't really even think pass
because they're killing us in the run
and I need to stay really honed in on
that and then Trent Brown is arguably
the biggest left tackle in football so
what's funny is sizes and an argument so
either is or he isn't and I believe you
yeah I believe he is right it's right up
there I mean it's him or a handful of
other got one or two other guys 6 9 3 v
and saying it's like Jason Peters would
be in that conversation and maybe Ronnie
Stanley give the note with the the
Baltimore Ravens but I think that was
the biggest thing that and Marcus cannon
is a huge right tackle he's a big dude
that's why I like setting the tone early
with the run because just the physical
toll of beating somebody and getting run
at right all of a sudden you think
you're gonna be able to like point your
ears back and you do right yeah I know
so they did that and
then they got back into they're not
afraid of third and two and third and
three and think about the game it was
third and two and third and three the
whole game which is exactly where you
want to be against that scheme a zone
scheme that we've talked about nine
million times and Josh McDaniels and
Belichick going back to the Super Bowl
planning and going back to Brady
throwing 39 completions and Super Bowl
xlix there's nobody better at finding
little ways to expose that zone to get
four yard completion first down I know
the Chiefs defenses secondary stinks but
at least they play man-to-man
they will play man-to-man and they're
gonna just chit because the Patriots are
about timing yes and they're not gonna
be scared of the speed of the Patriot
receivers and at least Kansas City has a
front for that they can say we we think
we can slow down the run by ourselves
what a lot of people would say that
Ingram and beau send those guys would
have been good enough yeah they would
have but they're not as big as Kansas
City Kansas City still big
Justin Houston is bigger than Melvin
Ingram or Joey Bosa you know what I mean
yes he is Joey Bosa I mean Dee Ford no
he's more of a speed guy but then Chris
Jones Fletcher Cox jr. yeah right
Chargers got no Chris Jones on their
team Chargers got really no album Alvin
Bailey yeah so right fake they could at
least go our front four should be able
to physically hang in there in the run
game to where maybe not have to be so
aggressive and coming up in the line of
scrimmage against the play-action pass
do you were you I don't know why I'm
like turning on TV and hearing podcast
and hearing people like almost shocked
by the Patriots Patriots were 11 and 1
at home in divisional games after a BA
yeah this is what they do I didn't think
that we're gonna blow them out I mean I
picked it to be a 23-17 game I thought
it was gonna be like 27 14 but I think
what we saw yeah I mean yeah you know
this is just a this is a a team that we
had said been underperforming on offense
having to make their second East Coast
trip in two weeks playing the one
o'clock game against a fresh football
team that was bigger and then of course
has the magic of Brady and Belichick it
was just a lot to overcome plus hey
Phillip Rivers you saw it you know one
of the things I think you're gonna see
next year is teams are gonna go why are
we even playing so
in the secondary he can't throw it more
than 39 yards in the air and I think
that's what the Patriots realized to
like okay if they want to throw a jump
ball at the 40-yard point
okay well live with that but we don't
really were not scared it's gonna be
like Tyree kill and they're gonna go by
us for 70 yards and you said because
anything you're kind of rooting for
Phillips yeah I was kind of rooting for
Phillips certainly but I mean gosh I got
over it pretty quick about the third
drive I was like alright this is over
let's get ready for the Eagles Saints
game I turned it off in the third ever I
would say early fourth quarter I started
making some snacks and I was like I had
an eye on and eye off and like every box
did you yeah
yeah and that's when I saw that my
broadcasters were gonna be Charles Davis
and Kevin Burkhardt and I went and I'm
already out I knew the Eagles were gonna
lose when I saw Charles Davis was
calling the game history doesn't happen
when Charles Davis is on the call your
brutal Charles Davis is a very good
broadcaster yeah he gives me nothing
other than what just happened yeah great
play there on third and five they picked
it up and when you pick it up that's
when you get a first down I didn't want
obviously 17 you get four more down
that's what he does okay yeah I know you
just can't do this cuz you're a big TV
guy oh yeah I'm big TV
look I'm the fifth estate I'm the only
one that's gonna tell you what the media
state so the media is known as the
Fourth Estate right because they
overlook all the other estates of
government okay and I'm saying on the
Fifth Estate is you're over this I'm
overlooking the meet are you gonna get
nothing by me I like that you like a lot
of things I do Oh before we move on to
the next game Brian Flores I like it so
look at the AFC East yeah
Miami coach goes to New York the
Patriots coach goes to Miami and Shawn
McDermott's up there and Buffalo going
and he's gotta offensive coordinator
who's from New England right but Bella
check of the Patriots they don't they
don't overturn any in division leavings
I thought that would be blocked
no no way you can't block them you can't
block a head lock it yep so you think
Bell chicks could be upset with Brian
Flores nope I don't think he is Brian
Flores would be like you know not not to
overstate it but I think he would look
at it was like a proud papa this is
this is a guy that came in this is truly
a Belichick disciple yes like you used
to say this all the time Romeo Crennel
and yeah Charlie white charlie weis
we're not true Belichick guys Parsa
ourselves rice but McDaniels and Flores
and Billy O'Brien Julio Bryan her yeah
Trisha yeah they're they came up the
ranks of New England from the beginning
and Brian Flores who played linebacker
at Boston College he slowly has worked
his way up and knows every little
intricacy of the whole organization so
he's seen it all you know again he
sounds like the most manly man ever oh
he's pretty tough he's one of those guys
where he looks into you you go you like
Gilman's want to look away cuz you like
him he's I think he sees my soul like
he's he has that kind of death stare at
you the way people are talking about him
compared to all of the other coaching
candidates that ever come out of New
England this one feels different yeah
all the other ones there was a yeah but
like even Patricia was like how much of
that defense was him but I'm not hearing
anyone asked that about Flores no I I
mean I think four is just the demeanor
his ability to lead men but you know the
fact that he has been there so long and
really understands how to run our
organization hey again just like some of
the other young guys what I like to have
seen them be a defensive coordinator for
another gear or juice something like
that
yes but he says a way bigger not Chuck
than the rest of those other guys too
because he's done way more on a daily
weekly basis then you know the Lafleur's
and the Zac Taylor's and the Kingsbury's
throughout the last ten years he really
knows all of it what's his position
Group specialty uh it's probably
secondary or linebackers I mean that's
really we're tied with Belichick they're
exactly right that's really where he
made his his rise in the and the
organizations you like Stephen Ross kind
of selling out and saying he's my guy
for the beginning I really do I just
think um I think Brian Flores is gonna
have a right the right vision for his
football team you know I think of
everything he's got a Spanish last name
in South Florida
of course I'm extremely well yeah I
don't know I give you credit for that I
would never I didn't think about you
know those thing I first of all I'm I'm
happy a black man got a damn head coach
job I'm just gonna say that because it's
a lot a bunch of [ __ ] so wait let me
just get this right look at all these
young white guys getting let me get to
this straight let me just get this
straight let me get this straight
Eric be enemy did not get a head
coaching job because it's being rumored
that he wasn't considered a quarterback
s pert so wait what what what what what
what what it what so the guy that
coached one of the best offenses in
football with the best quarterback in
football who's going to win the MVP and
they have this amazing offense he
doesn't get a job but yet the guy who
couldn't win with this guy in college or
the other coaches players he had in
college or couldn't win in general or
the guy who was at Tennessee and one of
the weakest points of the team was the
passing offense or the guy who came from
the Rams where we know it's all the head
coach and the quarterback hasn't really
been that impressive they got it cuz
they're better with the quarterback er
cuz they're white I don't know you just
got to tell me I'm just keeping a real
that's that's craziness that's craziness
I'm throwing the challenge flag on
everybody on the NFL with that [ __ ]
ass statement sorry gotta say that I
think it's very honest and it's very
fair and if we're gonna use our platform
correctly yeah you have to say those
yeah right it was such an obvious trend
in this year right and we're not trying
to be jerks to them but we're just
telling you the from 30,000 feet above
it doesn't look right it just looks
weird that the guy that's that we just
saw an offense right like it was like
Jim Tyree kill the power to go home and
if they're gonna be successful coaching
right they need to acknowledge that
they've been given an opportunity
earlier than they should yeah because
they're probably looking around their
respective locker rooms at guys that
have been in this profession for 20 to
30 years Vic Fangio and he was so proud
in his press conference that he didn't
reach out to Elway yeah he was contacted
by the rules the letter of the law Mike
Zimmer same thing with Minnesota these
guys won't campaign for anything they
won't talk to reporters I'll get a job
when I've earned a job and when I look
at Lafleur and Kliff Kingsbury and our
guy Zach Taylor I don't believe they've
earned those jobs doesn't mean they
can't do well they just got him earlier
than they should've because of
extenuating circumstances but be enemy
as you're saying is being forced to wait
he doesn't look like a quarterback
whisperer
he doesn't maybe look like a head coach
to some people and that's an optics
problem for them but it's unfortunate if
the main criteria is being a young
someone could look I mean Maggie got a
head coaching job cuz he took over the
play calling like what like halfway
through the year last year and now here
this offense doubles the Matt Nagy
Kansas City offense and it's like the
most unstoppable force we've seen in a
while on offense but we're gonna give
all the credit now to Andy Reid we got
to wait got it we got to wait on this
one not sure I don't know what else to
say everybody sorry no I think it's fair
I honestly I really think it's our duty
to say that I think it is I agree I
believe that with all my heart yep so
let's now go to well that was all the
games all right nice thank you so much
we didn't talk about drew Micah Thomas
we did talk about died sainthood all
right Lord Allie I am going to give you
the floor to break down what happened
okay and then I'm gonna explain how it's
all wrong okay okay explain how it's all
wrong all right so game starts off
Eagles Jordan Matthews touchdown big
interception yeah then they drive down
they score domination domination
domination to start the game I mean it
was like the typical case of you know
the one team was in playing like playoff
games for the last seven weeks I
legitimately thought by the way when all
three home teams and favorites started
off by looking like much better
I was excited right because I feel like
every year it's 3-1 are you right three
of them are clicking and then that last
team's like ready for it and they're
they're ready to battle back I mean yeah
it was it was unbelievable
and it looked like oh my gosh I mean the
of course the Saints looked flustered I
mean
and drew brees on some of them like when
they were going to commercial timeouts
like he was over I sitting on the water
cooler like oh no we're losing like I'm
a deep crap over here like he had that
look on his face first of all I mean
that should have been a walk-in
touchdown to start the game I mean he
under threw it by 15 yards that was a
touchdown I I don't think it's I think
it's fair to say that Drew Brees
didn't throw the best ball for the
Saints during the entire no taste some
hills bombs bomb that happened Camaro
was better than any Drew Brees throw
during the entire game I would agree
with that as well I mean expect that
wrinkle to come out a lot more yeah I
mean and it's a great wrinkle by then
but yeah you guys dominated the line of
scrimmage on both sides of the football
and your D line was just absolutely
destroying their old line early on I
think the best part about the game for
me
was America getting to see just how
great Fletcher Cox is yes for him to
leave and then to come back in and on
the very first play which was that taste
in Obama Alvin Kamara blow up Andrus
peat so bad who you believe is when the
best guards of the NFL that he had to
drag him down with him right
dude he destroyed Andrus peat he
destroyed everybody all day it was
incredible
but let's get to the turning point of
the game when Brandon Brooks got hurt
that was big when Fletcher Cox got hurt
no really the second second and eight
first of all interception that was big
the first Marshawn Lattimore when he
threw the ball up when Zach Ertz had a
step on a Marshawn laterally underthrown
Nick Foles on that was Nick Foles his
fault
exactly right I mean and again Marshall
not a Moore made a great catch and all
that and it was it was solid coverage
but yet there was a place to place that
ball down the field outside to where
yeah if you just you know it gives him a
chance but he made it a jump ball
situation and Lattimore can jump higher
them than Earth's and then it gets to
the sack Brandon Graham doesn't pick up
the fumble it gets challenged and all
that stuff and that's before that that's
before the second an eighth interception
so that's how you guys got the they
punted it you got the ball because they
overturned it and gave you guys who've
made it fourth down and they end up on
it no it's because no the Eagles decline
the penalty
making
fourth and one and then the Saints faked
the punt I know but the Brandon Graham
fumble happened before the 2nd and 8th
interception a hundred percent
oh so the interception came at 14-7 no
the inner yeah no it was 14 nothing here
I'll run it through I'll run it I'll run
it through through you here ok here we
go we got um let's see it's 14-0 drew
back in quarter yeah drew brees fumbles
no that's not that one second and Ted so
it's 14-0
I'm just we might have to cut out some
dead time here third and ten okay they
get the ink please shouldn't here we go
now it's third and eight it's 14 1400
third and eight and this is where the
Brandon Brandon Graham fumble happens
where man if he just falls on it you
guys are gonna be in great spot but
you're the Eagles and you play
aggressive and that's what you do so you
can't be mad at it for that so now they
punt now you guys get the ball back and
you're you're at the 48 yard line and he
throws the interception now of course
they get the ball they go first and ten
they get eight yards at second and two
they get one yard it's 3rd and 1 they
get nothing now it becomes 4th down so
your defense runs off the field then
they realize oh no we had to run back on
so I was yelling before take the penalty
right what is a yard to Sean Payton
Charles Davis vocally had an argument
with someone that didn't exist he
realized the announcer Charles Davis
yeah that he goes everyone's gonna kill
Doug Peterson for not taking that no no
no no everyone is going to naturally
defend Doug Peterson Charles Davis it's
your job to say that Doug Peterson
should have accepted that penalty sure
you're facing the New Orleans Saints
this is like facing the Chiefs or the
Patriots or the Rams those yards matter
it's third and 11 or or its or fourth
and one the Saints this is not the
Saints in the third quarter of the
fourth quarter this is the Saints in the
second quarter where their offense has
done nothing you just got to him and
caused the fumble the series before I
know you accept that penalty that I
thought Doug Peterson had three
for monster game farts in this brain
farts in this game right
that was one yeah the timeout in the
first drive of the second half that
didn't mean anything which you
eventually punted to plays later was one
that you needed that timeout the end of
the game right and then also rushing the
team up for the to get a play in before
the two-minute warning that was
interception I I don't I don't I was
applauding them going waste more time
we're at the 30 don't give drew brees
any time why are you rushing to do a
play yeah thanks 3 were such big brain
farts by Doug Peters they are they
definitely were I'm not gonna say this
one was his bigger brain fart to me and
I'll just just hear me out the first one
apart at least the the fart on their own
30 what it was on their own 30 you just
it was just third and one and you didn't
get they didn't they lost a half a foot
and you guys were whoopin their ass so I
think he's gone oh you want to go for it
like go ahead I haven't seen you block
foot your [ __ ] or Jernigan yet so I
think he's playing that aspect
now what happens no but if they're in
punt I'm the entire time if I'm beating
the [ __ ] out of a team right I'm in punt
safe every time now this is where it
gets interesting it wouldn't have
mattered no they were in punt safe but
you're Cox was that deepens a tackle and
then he got hurt on the same he got hurt
that was a double whammy he got hurt on
that play and you guys got blown back
because I don't think the players really
thought they were gonna fake it look at
who's on the field for the New Orleans
Saints if you could pull up the
highlight it's guys blocking Michael
Bennett and Fletcher Cox that's girl
have no right to be doing it but I don't
think your D line really believed they
were gonna do it Fletcher Cox gets hurt
he's the best player on the field in the
game period there's nobody better on the
field like seven player though exactly
right I mean you could argue Fletcher
Cox is it's Erin Donald and then it's
like a toss-up between Cox and Kaleo Mac
for the second best defensive player in
football I mean that's how awesome he is
so he gets hurt that was first of all we
got to give Sean Payton credit for such
a gutsy call changing the momentum of a
football game but the game was never
same from that point on so then he gets
hurt you mentioned it Michael Bennett
gets hurt
believe on the same series just a few
plays later I mean we lost Russell
Douglas gets hurt
let's up the touchdown pass because you
got the guy that's in there but I can't
remember his name yet Corey Hawkins hawk
Josh hawk Josh Hawkins right who messes
up the switch that you're supposed to
have on the 4th and 2 touchdown pass and
yes and then Brandon Brooks gets hurt I
think the next series are either way it
was not long after who's you know in the
convo from one of the better guards and
all of football definitely one of the
most powerful guards in football that's
a great matchup for what the Saints do
the Eagles after Brandon Brooks went
down yeah
tried to pull the right guard on runs
like three or four times right and they
even go anywhere negative yeah Stefan
was Nueske's pulling around the end and
Darren Sproles is being taken down for a
one-yard gain right
he was the that right side the offensive
line was everything for the eagle right
everything yeah I know
so now that I of all the Eagles fans why
didn't we change up what we do on
defense you know why did we keep playing
zone well we're gonna put Josh Josh
Hawkins man you were gonna do that and
go oh we think that'll work out okay if
they did on like a third and 60s he was
playing like 20 yards off right so like
okay you got to be scared of that first
and the other thing is you guys have
gotten where you've gotten to this point
because you started playing sound zone
defenses the game was ruined for you
guys because Fletcher Cox and Michael
Bennett were not a hundred percent and
they couldn't play the regular role they
only played on third downs or some big
down situations they couldn't stay in
consistently and what has been saving
you know your secondary is the fact that
your front fours been dominating teams
and you don't have Ronald are because
you got hurt Rodney McCloud got hurt now
you got a Russel Douglas hurt Avante
Maddox is limping a little bit in the
game there's no way you could ever
change it up and we talked about the man
first game crow Vaughn LeBlanc and all
those guys got thrown in because of
injuries and Kelsey only played 60 right
the Eagles didn't lose to the Saints the
Eagles lost to the Superdome turf and I
know lost Sheldon ranken's to us so
let's not forget because he's damn good
we're gonna trade one for us Evan I'm
just telling you it got them to but and
Josh was
you're gonna sound like sour grapes but
looking purple but like this is like
them losing Sheldon Rankin's and cam uh
cam Jordan Jordan right and Andres Pete
yeah and Marsha and Lattimer well why
did you give why are you getting all
these injuries cuz those are the ones we
had what you I'm saying you had Fletcher
Cox a brand new Brooks oh and Michael
Bessey you're giving yeah okay okay
you're Andrew Sewell died right like
yeah that's big this big dude I just
felt the thing that killed me was I
didn't felt like we lost straight up I
didn't feel like they beat our best team
is what is the reason I think like I
actually father's me too and I don't
even I don't even care about you guys
know what I mean I know what you mean
because you want to see teams in these
situations happy I'm happy to say that
the Saints are point are the best team
in the NFL right now they're the most
complete team in the NFL right now
unless the Chiefs has Sammy Watkins then
it gets dicey but they beat us they won
the game congratulations I'm hoping that
you guys have a good run and that this
magical season continues I said this
when you guys beat the Ravens that this
was the year of destiny for Drew Brees
I've been saying this all season long
but I just wanted the Saints to beat the
Eagles straight up and to look out there
and see Haloti Ngata and Hester allowing
like 20-yard runs to Alvin Kamara on an
18 play drive yes
you guys mowed down the field but that
wasn't the Eagles I don't even know who
Hawkins is I found out that he was
signed on Christmas Eve I didn't know
this man existed I didn't know he
existed I know dude and now I'm hearing
Saints fans and I'm hearing broadcasters
and I'm hearing pundits say that Michael
Thomas is hands-down the best wide
receiver in the NFL he did it against
the guy I've never heard of on slant
routes well I'm playing eye contact once
they got play-action and once they got
you guys any probable wide open yeah I
just I sometimes I understand that we
can explain things with numbers and
stuff and I know that I'm gonna seem
like a hater but I'm just saying that
like we can also be like objective and
go who was really guarding him what was
really the defense
situation and maybe we're making a lot
now I will say this he's one of the best
wide receivers in the league and I'm not
debating that I got it but the waxing
poetic after beating Josh Hawkins do you
want to know what really happened in
this game so wait one more thing okay
the other thing I can tell you the real
reason the Eagles lost you know again we
always get back to issue a you know I I
really think these are issues that you
know you will pointed out a million
times this year too and we always talk
about kryptonite another thing that
hurts your team was and we've been
worried about this is they were able to
play man in some situations because
there's no one to be scared of going
deep on your team I'm gonna break it
down from Buell's fan perspective of all
the weapons as the defense held the
Saints to 20 point right that should be
enough to win that should be especially
when you have 14 in the frame the dome
in New Orleans
yes Golden Tate is not good when Nick
Foles is in in terms of playing the ball
he needed to draw the P I on that one
deep pass he needed to come back to the
ball he didn't he tried to be cute and
work right Nelson Aguilar had two or
three major brain farts including one
not recognizing the Blitz and not
turning around to a beautiful throw by
oval I know that whizzed right by his
face right I don't know if that was his
fault but Zach Ertz it's just not
physical sometimes and in the game like
that he needed to be didn't have it
Dallas Goddard didn't exist yeah I don't
think he made it in time I was yeah yeah
I don't think the running backs Wendel
Smallwood started off early I think the
loss of Brandon Brooks really messed
that up did and I thought Al Shean
played a phenomenal game except for the
last thrill yeah and the fact that I
wrote down midway through the game Al
Shean is my favorite receiver he still
is al shot is my favorite receiver
that's ever played for the Eagles yeah
more than Harold Carmichael
yeah because Baltimore 7 he's a [ __ ]
talker that bleeds green right now and
he plays hard and his ability to jump
over guys is incredible he really has an
elite ability yeah you pushed him man
damn you mushed him holy crap
I mean with your talk on Thursday and
Wednesday and then so lay that let's
crichton down that came oh my god get to
why the Eagles really lost can't believe
me much - I feel like that before the
game I decided because that game was
kind of done the Patriots Chargers I
said you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
repot my orchid you're gonna roll your
fatty is that what they meant no like I
legitimately love it or repot my rolling
of my pot no no generally my plant out
of I have a plant right I took it out
and I was putting more soil in there
right and I didn't want to get my shirt
dirty so I was shirtless okay
well I'm in my apartment yeah Oh think
about that people but it got a little it
took a little bit longer than it should
have and so I hear kevin burkhart be
like add we're off and I'm like alright
well I'm done with this and I laid on
the couch and I assumed the position
I don't normally take my shirt off until
third quarter if necessary
why because it's sort of like
in-case-of-emergency cracked glass why
do the Eagles show them out to that lead
because I was in my fourth quarter
position in the first quarter you can
laugh they came out hot and I'm sitting
there and I'm going nuts and I can't
believe him
and that's when I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up their I get a text message
from the founder of bleacher report
David are finocchio finocchio you jinx
are still talking about how we can pay
carson wentz and nick foles we came out
with a system that if you offer them 35
million combined and no one gets below
ten and it's based on how many games you
play so if one guy starts the whole
season they get 20 the other guy gets 10
it's a great way of doing it I thought
it was a great idea not the time to have
that conversation I get a text message
from our former manager over at overtime
mark cone and he's offering me Laremy
Tunsil and a first-round pick for Carson
Wentz I respond and say it'll take two
first and Laremy Tunsil
great idea not the time I'm getting text
messages from you guys congratulations
left go this is so great left go
this is exactly how it's supposed to be
I was enjoying it and I'm sitting there
and I'm going you're right I was
enjoying seeing the Saints gonna be
impression I'm feeling good yeah
but then there was a moment right at the
end of the first quarter I go on and I
said let me see how my Twitter mentions
are doing I just want to enjoy this
moment and there was this one over the
hill I just know that Adam Lefko is
sitting on his couch shirtless in a
predetermined position winning this game
for the Eagles and I took a screenshot
are you kidding me 5:15 and I said did
you screenshot yourself on the couch
about it that much I looked out the
window and said maybe he's a neighbor
but in my head I went I'm [ __ ] win in
this game for the [ __ ] Eagles and
then Sims I went on [ __ ] Twitter and
I waited until the first quarter was
over because I didn't want anything to
[ __ ] happen I said I'm gonna wait
until once the fourth quarter is over
and then I'm gonna fire out this tweet
because I want this day chronicled I
want to write my own history and this is
what I [ __ ] tweeted read it out loud
did everyone enjoy the first quarter
with Thanos a thanos [ __ ] gift Oh a
Thanos gift lay left go thinnest I shot
my complete wad in the first quarter
yeah I had conversations about trading
whence I had conversations about paying
both I had conversations about success
and joy and and I literally was thinking
about coming on this podcast I want to
say to all of Philadelphia I am so sorry
I cannot believe that I took something
that had such promise and I threw it
away like that and don't blame this on
Al Shean not catching the ball don't
blame this on Doug Peterson's bad
decisions
I am the reason to blame for the Eagles
losing and I am so sorry to the city of
Philadelphia I'm sorry to this team and
I'm embarrassed it's all about you I'm
just a pop I'm just doing my part I did
you hear me Nick got my text Nick or yet
Nick sorry let's go save sorrow so
tomorrow the Saints are still playin
you're at home with no shirt on hey
you're watching Drew and Mike ah
championship Sunday way to go Nick
way to go kid I will say this though
it's the first time what right after the
game you know what I did but I'd booked
a vacation it's like he was on the team
Josh like oh man those double teams are
rough today honey
yeah I got a book of vacation I'm gonna
say this once we got to the fourth
quarter yeah and they were attempting
the field goal yeah I had had some
success reassume in the position right
and I went and I'm still shirtless and I
grabbed the seat cushions and I'm
yelling at my girlfriend to get in the
other room and she's like why and I go
cuz that's where you were for the Bears
oh my god and she looked at me and she
goes I'm not going and I went and I
cursed and then the kick went off and he
missed it and I was like the locks back
right we're back okay so then what what
are you thinking as you're getting the
ball and now a four were driving down
the field is on I'm going this is this
is how it's always been meant to be
now what doing this again right now what
were you saying when they ran when you
pan ran up for the two minutes because
I'm right away going though this is
great I didn't think that I was a good
great let the two point let the
two-minute warning happen here I was
yelling why are they rushing right
legitimate and then give me your
thoughts as you were going through the
play itself I thought the play actually
made a lot of sense yeah I mean if
you're gonna run up to get a playoff
slant over the middle makes sense right
because it's it's usually something
where that the other teams probably like
defending the other teams probably like
defending the sidelines and so the
middle should be open he came and said
hey Nick Foles I want more interceptions
the babadook Dook gonna have some gumbo
on Philadelphia I'm gonna put a little
Eagle stew in this one sorry I just kind
of collapsed way to go Nick I I will say
though that I really do feel like we
lost to the Superdome yeah and I just
want to say that my entire life has been
defined as an Eagles fan of huge playoff
losses I wen Ronde Barber took one of
the house yeah I remember how I felt
when Rickey Manning junior picked off
Donovan threes
I remember when Donovan and the Eagles
lost in the Superbowl to Rodney Harrison
on that last interception right I seen
this story to the Saints many times
Eagles losing at home to the Saints
Eagles losing in New Orleans after
Sheldon Brown had that huge hit
I remember the loss to Arizona where
they didn't call pass interference
against Kevin Curtis and it totally was
that awesome Jeff Garcia year I remember
the loss of Mike Vick lobbing it up to
the Packers and all those I felt like
[ __ ] for a week yeah I woke up at 7 a.m.
today I've been more productive than I
ever have been and for the first time
after an eagle's loss this is gonna
sound weird
I feel gratitude hey should this has
been an Eagles team that is no longer
going to exist Nick Foles is going to be
gone Golden Tate is going to be gone
Brandon Graham will likely be gone
there's a number of players on but who
knows what's gonna happen with Jason
Peters is Chris long gonna keep playing
right the Eagles are about to go into
flux mm-hmm like that like I just
genuine like III believe in the court I
believe in B yeah
but there was gonna be some roster
turnover well and Brandon Brooks Tory's
Achilles yeah he's gonna be out for a
long time that's the worst injury you
can get ready much yeah and so I'm
sitting here and I don't know what the
future
the Eagles but I will say that it's
probably because they won the Super Bowl
and it's a little bit firm this team but
what a beautiful ride hey it was awesome
and I don't know you don't have anything
to be disappointed up
you really don't I mean the curse is
gone forever and your team this was like
a story that you don't see this Super
Bowl champs because yeah the middle part
of the season usually Super Bowl champs
you fall apart the middle part of the
season they go well we won the Super
Bowl last year we'll see you next year
you guys rallied then again to be in the
conversation for oh my gosh you might be
one of the best teams in the NFL and
really yes got a little unlucky
yesterday in the Saints game played a
very good Saints team to but yes was
there for the taking once again and I
think that's commendable and rare you
don't see that a lot in the NFL I
remember that after the first Saints
came and I said it last time all the
articles were worst Superbowl year the
next year and I think other than the
Patriots teams that always seem to come
back to next year yeah they have been
the best rebound performance of any team
in like a long time right other than the
Patriots cuz they're not even compared
now you can't they're Patriots on
another level and I let me just say this
before we go to all the Saints fans
congratulations I mean this sincerely
like I had a lot of fun trolling my
mentions were insane Sims is probably
gonna play the music one more time
because he's texting but I I don't want
to till the scissors we'll see y'all
Sunday yeah 3:30
All Saints a goal but I'm happy for
camara yeah I'm happy for Ingram I'm
happy for trolled you guys have it the
game yeah but you know what like we
would've told them to problem yeah
that's right
I'm happy for Sean Payton because if
Sean Payton's able to get another Super
Bowl he's really gonna go down as one of
the best coaches of all time yeah it
should be I'd be but to all the Saints
fans I had a lot of saints fans in my
mention saying hey man I'm a Saints fan
I didn't like the [ __ ] talking too much
but I'm sorry that it happened I allowed
it to all those guys yeah
I appreciate you you guys are great
Eagles fans keep your head up Saints
good luck I think we're gonna have it's
the four best remaining offenses in the
NFL yeah it's gonna be think about this
and I'm gonna wrap it up like this the
three best regular-season games of the
year
entertaining wise we're Chiefs Rams
Monday night
Patriots chief Sunday night and Rams
Saints four o'clock we're getting two of
the rematches this week and there's a
chance to get the third on the Super
Bowl yeah it's pretty special it is
pretty special and it's it's for coaches
that all four can use the last
experience as a way of making this next
game better there's no huge coaching gap
McVeigh and Peyton phenomenal Belichick
and read a battle as old as time
love it it's gonna be great football for
championship weekend yeah well can't
wait to watch it at your place for seven
peace out homies force pendrick nice and
fer the lef koe man we will open it now
I'm not even asked him to do this well
holla holla holla
all right hit us up on social ad citizen
love go and as always email us sims in
love code gmail.com tell us which night
you're going to come down and Atlanta
for the Superbowl it's gonna be a blast
you